bonjour à toutes et bonjour à tous
quelques mots pour vous inviter à
repenser la ville en termes à la fois
des espaces de temps et de rythme alors
vous croyez peut-être que ce sont des
choses des approches qui ne vous
concerne pas et en fait elle vous
concerne au premier chef
d'abord la ville c'est notre espace et
on en a pas d'autres ça c'est ce que
nous disait l'écrivain georges perec
deuxième élément pour tenter de vous
convaincre c'est le fait que la ville
s'est généralement défini comme le lieu
de maximisation des interactions et
aujourd'hui avec les évolutions en cours
et notamment la crise de l'aco vide
cette ville à l'est mise à l'épreuve
troisième élément pour tenter aussi et
encore de vaud convaincre c'est le fait
qu'avant la crise vous passiez sans
doute pas mal de votre temps à dire des
choses suivantes ras-le-bol des
embouteillages
cette maison est devenue un hôtel on ne
se voit plus je suis fatigué je suis
épuisée je cours tout temps j'en ai
marre de faire ce qu'on appelle le
parent taxi en tout cas j'entendais
autour de moi ce type de deux messages
et la vous pouvez constater qu'il s'agit
bien de question de temps des espaces et
de mobilité donc vous êtes bien toutes
et tous convoqués est concerné par cette
réflexion sur le temps l'espace et et
les mobilités
avant de poursuivre vous dire quand même
touche pas je crois que c'est important
je suis géographe
je suis professeur à l'insa de toulouse
c'est à dire un géographe vous en avez
rencontrées dans votre scolarité
j'imagine que géographiquement
généralement aux trois questions la
question du quoi et qui la question du
coût et ensuite celle du pourquoi ils
essayent d'expliquer d'expliquer les
choses d'un point de vue spatial et ils
fabriquent généralement des cartes
moi je fais partie de ces géographe qui
ont essayé d'introduire une nouvelle
question c'est la question du camp ah
quelle heure quelle saison
quel jour à kehl à quel moment alors
pourquoi cette question du temps
ici et maintenant on peut constater
ensemble qu'on pense souvent la ville en
terme d' espace est très très peu
finalement
en termes de temps et pourtant si vous
observez la ville elle n'est pas tout à
fait la même le matin à midi le soir
début de la nuit coeur de nuit et le
matin
pourtant laborde comme si c'était un une
entité à naître j'allais dire un être
moyen on réfléchit encore trop souvent
la ville comme si elle ne fonctionnait
aussi que 16 heures sur 24 et comme
s'ils allaient fonctionner que 5 jours
sur 7 là aussi c'est étrange
et enfin dernière dernier élément on
aménage souvent l'espace pour gagner du
temps et là je vais prendre l'exemple du
tgv qui a rétréci finalement la france
et l europe le train à grande vitesse
mais on aménage très peu le temps pour
gagner de l'espace
cette situation elle est en train de
changer et et nous nous sommes obligés
de changer de regard avant qu'il soit
trop tard et changer de regard et de
paradigme par rapport à cette approche
de la ville alors premier élément qui
nous oblige à changer c'est le fait que
nos villes grignote l'espace naturel et
agricole utile un chiffre on considère
généralement que tous les sept ans il ya
l'équivalent d'un département français
donc la surface d'un département
français qui disparaissent ou
l'urbanisation
donc ça c'est un élément important le
deuxième on a de plus en plus de
conflits d'usagé dans une ville qui est
désormais un plusieurs temps parce qu'on
a pu les mêmes rythmes de fonctionnement
les mêmes temps sociaux et notamment la
nuit
on le sait dans les villes
universitaires ou la ville qui dort ok
c'est de dormir rentrer en conflit avec
la ville qui s'amusaient troisième
élément en passe de plus en plus de
temps dans les transports pour essayer
de joindre l'autre bout des métropoles
éclaté on habitants dès que paul virilio
avait appelé
aidés des outres ville c'est-à-dire des
villes
au delà de la ville et on tente de
rejoindre un point de cette métropole
lumeta paul ou mégalopole en utilisant
évidemment les transports et on perd
beaucoup de temps là dedans on a
beaucoup de mal aussi à se synchroniser
en famille en entreprise et dans les
villes on entend souvent on se voit plus
ça c'est un élément souvent de
diagnostic composent aux rencontres de
moins en moins c'est pas parce qu'on
n'habite pas la même ville qu'on
n'habite pas le même appartement le même
quartier ou qu'on travaille pas dans la
même entreprise mais tout simplement on
est dans les mêmes espaces mai puis au
même moment puis dernier élément on est
de plus en plus décalé avec les rythmes
naturels et là on a bien des questions
d'articulation des espaces et des temps
il me semble que ce modèle n'est plus
soutenable pour ne pas utiliser le terme
un peu ambigu de durable et il me semble
qu'on doit pouvoir intégrer le temps
comme un levier des politiques de
développement durable au même titre que
l'énergie ou l'espace ce qui me semble
important également c'est le fait que la
pandémie a été l'occasion d'y réfléchir
seul ou ensemble je crois que pendant le
confinement on a tous pris le temps de
mener une introspection introspection
sur nos vies sur l'accélération sur nos
libertés sur nos manières de consommer
mais aussi sur nos manières d'habiter au
sens physique mais aussi poétique du
monde
deuxième élément de son multi
l'important dans cette relation à
l'espace et au temps on en latin la
pandémie c'est le fait que la proximité
est devenue une dimension centrale en
termes de service et et d'alimentation
c'est presque de souveraineté dont il
s'agit on a aussi mesuré l'importance de
certaines choses simples qui prennent du
temps et on voit le succès des émissions
par exemple de de cuisine faire un repas
on a appris aurait appris à cuisiner et
à donner du temps à ça on dit aussi
qu'on a appris à donner du temps à son
conjoint ou sa conjointe à la famille à
des choses qui étaient devenus peut-être
s'était passé au second plan dans une
ville et dans des activités de plus en
plus accélérée autre élément issu
peut-être de cette de cette crise qu'on
vit ensemble c'est le fait qu'on n'a
plus envie de faire des dizaines de
kilomètres chaque jour pour aller
travailler
en gros les français font de 20
kilomètres à vol d'oiseau pour rejoindre
leur lieu de travail à partir du
domicile
mais en même temps on n'a pas toujours
envie de passer des journées devant nos
écrans
il me semble que les uns et les autres
celles et ceux qui avaient la chance de
ne pas être confronté directement au
virus est là j'aimerais quand même avoir
une pensée pour les premiers de corvée
on avait parlé de premier de cordée mais
il ya aussi les premiers de corvée
celles et ceux qui ont continué à
travailler pendant qu'on était dans nos
métiers notamment à l'abri de nos
appartements donc et à ce moment là on a
bien compris l'importance de l'espace
public et de l'extérieur je crois que
quand on regarde l espace public quand
on regardait les cafés fermés quand on
regardait les places les places vides on
se rendait bien compte de l'importance
de l'extérieur et de l'espace public une
importance qui sera accrue pendant le
déconfinement et dernier élément sans
doute plus important c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la question de la qualité
de la vie une bonne qualité de la vie et
au coeur de la réflexion d'un certain
nombre de personnes et de responsables
alors ma contribution par rapport à ça
elle est simple moi je pense que pour
retrouver la maîtrise des temps de nos
villes et des temps de nos vies je vous
propose trois choses qui sont une façon
de les présenter différentes mais qui
rejoignent le même
première c'est utiliser la clé des temps
comme un levier pour le développement
soutenable
on a vu on a l'habitude de travailler
sur en termes de développement durable
sur la question de l'espace sur la
question de l'énergie qui est pas là pas
ma question en tant que géographe donc
essayé d'utiliser la clé des temps
j'aime bien cette figure là le deuxième
c'est de réfléchir à la ville pas comme
quelque chose de données et de définitif
mais comme quelque chose de malléable de
réversible et d'adaptabilité idée de la
ville comme un rythme et une manière de
flux est quelque chose qui soit capable
de résister aux crises car les crises se
succèdent
on est de plus en plus dans
l'incertitude il faut être capable de
construire ces écosystèmes qui vont
réagir et troisième élément qui vous
concerne peut-être moins si vous n'êtes
pas des spécialistes de l'urbanisme mais
qui me concerne plus moi même et mes
collègues c'est cette idée de construire
ce qu'on a appelé un urbanisme des temps
et en urbanisme des rythmes
vous allez me dire il est en train de
nous perdre parce que le terme et est
complexe
urbanisme rythme est en jeu j'ai imaginé
que je pouvais vous donner quelques
petits exemples et décliné la
proposition
autour de quelques principes le premier
très simple il s'agit d'aménager le
temps pour gagner l'espace souvenez-vous
au début de mon propos je disais qu'on
aménage souvent l'espace pour gagner du
temps
comment on peut faire le contraire
puisque on adopte cette clé d'entrée
temporel voir spatio temporelle on peut
par exemple inscrire dans les documents
d'urbanisme qui sont les plans locaux
d'urbanisme ou les schémas de cohérence
territoriale et des instruments pour
organiser nos villes l'interdiction de
construire des immeubles d'habitation à
plus de dix minutes
da pôle de services et travaillez donc
ça c'est la première proposition
la deuxième proposition c'est de penser
la ville le quartier et vos appartements
comme un espace d espace hybride
c'est-à-dire où les activités peuvent
cohabiter à proximité donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut imaginer de plus séparer les
activités comme c'est le cas dans la
ville actuelle qui issus de la charte
d'athènes ou sur un bout des espaces il
ya une
non c'est de se dire qu'on peut avoir
sur un espace plusieurs fonctions c'est
la fameuse mixité mais on le dit
beaucoup on le fait peu et c'est une
mixité qu'on trouve aujourd'hui dans des
lieux qui intéresse qui sont une forme
un peu d des nouvelles organisations de
villes qui sont les tirs lieu donc c'est
pas un lieu de travail
c'est pas un lieu de résidence et ses
interviews troisième proposition
aménager le temps pour lutter contre les
encombrements
quand on a des encombrements dans une
ville le matin ou le soir
qu'est ce qu'on fait on rajoute un tube
on rajoute une voiture sur l'autoroute
ont un système de transport il ya une
autre solution
il suffirait de décaler les horaires
d'entrée le matin dans certaines
entreprises collectivités organisation
et le soir pour qu'on passe du bouchon
de l'encombrement à la fluidité du
trafic
mais ça ça demande de l'intelligence
collective sa demande du partenariat et
et les changes
par contre ça oblige pas à produire
comme on le faisait dans la modernité
des kilomètres d'autoroutes quatrième et
avant dernière proposition
c'est sans doute celle qui mit qui
m'intéresse le plus à laquelle je tiens
le plus c'est de réfléchir la ville les
quartiers et les bâtiments dont toujours
de façon multiscalaire comme une salle
polyvalente
alors c'est pas très comment dire
désirable une salle polyvalente quand on
pense aux salles polyvalentes des
villages de notre enfance mais c'est
c'est l'idée qui est importante c'est à
dire que on va avoir des activités qui
vont se succéder au fil du temps des
heures de la journée des moins des
saisons jusqu'à présent quand on a une
fonction dans une ville quand on pense à
une activité à une fonction qu'est ce
qu'on fait on fabrique un nouvel objet
célibataire qu'on va mettre en
périphérie dans la proposition que je
fais c'est qu'au contraire on essaye
d'accumuler sur le même espace
différentes activités au coeur de pan
dans la même journée pendant la même
semaine
par exemple le fait que
campus universitaire puisse être utilisé
l'été pour d'autres activités qu'à
bâtiments publics en journée puisse
devenir un dortoir la nuit pour les sdf
qu'une école le jour puisse devenir un
espace de réunion en soirée c'est pas si
compliqué ça demande de la confiance de
l' échange du partenariat et là on gagne
finalement de l'espace on n'est pas
obligé d'utiliser un est de construire
un nouveau bâtiment puisqu'on en a déjà
à disposition au 5e et dernier élément
c'est l'idée de garder des espaces et
des temps disponible pour s'adapter et
je vais dire un mot sur la pandémie qui
nous concerne
en ce moment c'est l'idée que les rues
les parcs les places peuvent aujourd'hui
lors du de déconfinement accueillir des
terrasses et des commerces
donc ça veut dire que quand vous avez
vécu le confinement et on sait que
c'était très très difficile
heureusement qu'on avait des espaces à
proximité qui avaient des berges qui
avait un petit peu d espaces publics et
autres donc on veut faire la ville sur
la ville mais il me semble qu'il faut
qu'on laisse de la place pour des
possibles les adaptations
alors pour conclure car il faut conclure
je vais inviter les acteurs de la
fabrique urbaine mais aussi vous toutes
et vous tous à utiliser cette clé des
temps et les rythmes pour deux choses
limiter la consommation des espaces
agricoles et naturels et 2 éviter la
dilution de la ville en favorisant l'
intensité urbaine
je crois que c'est une chance et c'est
une opportunité pourquoi une chance et
une opportunité
d'abord parce que la question concerne
tout le monde
si je vous parle d'économie si je parle
de social si je parle de technologie
il ya des sachants et finalement on se
sent un peu exclu du débat là sur la
question du temps chacun a quelque chose
à dire
et de toute façon la question concerne
tout le monde que ce soit le public le
privé les organisations et les individus
on est toutes et tous des donneurs de
temps mais aussi des acteurs qui
subissent un certain nombre de
temporalité donc première chose ça
concerne tout mon deuxième c'est une
compétence partagée qui va
obligé aux partenariats et aux dialogues
et on sait qu'on est dans une société de
séparation encore qu'ils fonctionnent
encore trop en silo on veut du
transversale on veut mettre les choses à
plat
c'est la possibilité de le faire à
partir de la question du temps d'autant
que cette notion de temps elle concerne
des aspects très concret de la vie
quotidienne et de la proximité un
décalage des horaires de transport
décalage d'une entrée dans une et des
horaires d'une école et des choses qui
renvoie à cette fameuse vie quotidienne
et j'allais presque dire utiliser ce
terme aux vrais gens que les politiques
sont toujours en train de rechercher sur
les marchés les vrais gens ils sont
partout ils sont ici à côté de moi ils
sont partout donc il suffit de les
regarder fonctionner dans leur quotidien
évidemment ils n'ont pas toutes et tous
les même quotidiens
ça renvoie aussi la dimension du temps à
des dimensions sensible et humaine et
quand on parle d'aménagement du
territoire d'urbanisme on est souvent
dans des notions qui sont techniques qui
sont sûrs de la matérialité là on
renvoie à du sensible quand on parle de
temps qu'on discute avec un père une
mère célibataire qui courent toute la
journée pour amener son gamin à l'école
qui voit là on est sur des choses
vraiment qui touche à la vie parfois on
est dans la nostalgie quand on parle de
la nuit du temps d'avant voilà donc ça
renvoie des dimensions sensible c'est
très important ça oblige à
l'intelligence collective tout le monde
parle d'intelligence collective nous on
parle même d' intelligence territoriale
on a beaucoup de difficulté à le faire
sauf à parler de ville intelligente de
smart cities et de et d'interconnexion
permanente mais je crois que
l'intelligence collective c'est ce qu'on
doit construire pour la ville de demain
et il me semble également que la crise
sanitaire nous y invite alors pour
terminer je
déterminée non pas avec mes propres
propositions
mais avec deux conseils qui m'ont été
donnés l'un directement par un
chronobiologistes et l'autre par un
sociologue
le premier chrono biologiste s'appelle
bernard millet et il m'a rappelé un jour
qu'on réfléchisse et sur la ville 24
heures sur 24
il m'a rappelé la chose suivante sans
rythme pas de vie et le second c'est
craquant ware qui était sociologue lui
je pas eu la chance de le rencontrer il
disait on reconnaît une ville à la place
qu'elle laisse à l'improvisation
donc c'est quelqu'un qui travaille dans
l'urbanisme dans la géographie dans
l'aménagement qui vous dis aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'il ne faut pas tout aménagé
et sans doute qu'il faut apprendre à
ménager
merci